dr. Stanley is the director of the
suicide prevention training
implementation evaluation program at New
York State Psychiatric Institute she's a
professor in the department of
psychiatry and a visiting professor at
the University of Oslo so we're very
pleased to have her with us today
I'll give you dr. Sam thank you very
much for inviting me to speak today so I
just want to put up my disclosure which
is mostly my funding sources here and I
want to start with what are the goals of
my presentation first of all talk a
little bit about suicide as a problem
but in particular suicide as a problem
in borderline personality disorder and
[Music]
what are some novel approaches to
understanding suicidal behavior what are
strategies that we have developed in
working with suicidal individuals and I
just want to say that in my presentation
today I'm gonna really focus on the
clinical side of things as opposed to
presenting research data I have I where
well actually now three hats but the you
know mostly think of myself as a
researcher but I'm also a clinician and
I've worked with suicidal individuals
particularly suicidal individuals with
borderline personality disorder for many
many years and so while I draw on both
the research side and the clinical side
I really want to kind of focus on the
clinical side of things with that said
I'm going to talk about some data in the
beginning so one thing I'm gonna point
out here to you is that earlier it was
mentioned this is the funding for
borderline personality disorder well I'm
a borderline personality disorder but
I'm also a suicide researcher and really
down at the bottom of the barrel here is
suicide research so if you are a
researcher on suicidal behavior and
borderline personality disorder you're
really in trouble
and and so if you compare it to for
example and this is what what people
have been talking about earlier about
signing that petition and becoming an
advocacy group I think it's incredibly
important because look at what has
happened with autism and this is a
population that has been very very
active in in demanding on that research
be done and that funds be devoted and so
you it is possible to increase the
amount of funding so that's my pitch
okay so suicide has taken on a lot of
time in the press over the last few
years and so I've been in the field for
a really long time
and and this was what it looked like and
so this is really why it's really
important to not assume kind of
causality so over these years what
happened here was there was the
introduction of of SSRIs and so
everybody thought oh look we have the
suicide problem licked suicide rate is
going down we have these great new
antidepressants and then as everybody
else has presented today already the
suicide rate has gone up okay
so oops I'm sorry so what I want to
point out here is that over the last
several years of the ten leading causes
of death of which suicide is one the the
numbers of those people who died by
those leading causes has gone down in
every single one or has at least stayed
the same except in suicide suicide is
the only one where it's going up so
something is really wrong here okay so
I'm not going to belabor this too much
we are ready we heard earlier that we
now have a problem and this is huge in
the suicide field we have a problem in
middle-aged group it was always the
older white male that was our highest
suicide risk group that no longer is the
case so I put this out here for you
because this is just looking at males
and females and we know that females are
much less likely to die by suicide and
the people who we see in our clinical
practice who have borderline personality
disorder are much more likely to be
female but if you look at what is
happening over the last few years this
is females only and you could see in
this something is going on here not just
with middle-aged men but also with
middle-aged women where the suicide rate
in middle-aged women is going up and so
we would expect that that might
translate into an increase in suicide
and borderline - so as a suicide
researcher one of the things that I
always point out this year the 2014 the
firearm rate goes just below 50% but um
in the United States and this is
particularly the United States about
half the people who die by suicide do
but die by firearms it's incredible and
so when I talk about safety planning in
a little while we always talk about
access to firearms okay so this I think
is really important for us to take a
look at here so this is what is the if
you try to kill yourself with the
firearm what is the so-called success
rate the fatality rate 85% of people die
if you do try to kill yourself by
poisoning which is a drug overdoses it's
a much smaller rate of death so it's
very hard to kill yourself by drugs it's
very easy to kill yourself by suicide
men use guns women use pills the other
thing that I think is
important for us to remember is kind of
like the the incidence of substance use
and and suicide and that's not it's it's
not that so much that substances are
used to die but but substances are often
on board at the time of death in the the
highest incidence of substances that
death is is alcohol so about a third of
people who die by alcohol have have who
died by suicide have had alcohol before
their death
this is particularly alarming on twenty
almost twenty one percent have opiates
on board and this is probably going up
with the increased use of opiates okay
so we already know this I'm not going to
go through all of these figures here um
there are many many more males died by
suicide females more often make suicide
attempts and I will go through all of
these figures here you have them in your
brochure so do suicide attempts predict
suicide and so if we we look at this
case in in Europe where they looked at
more than 21,000 cases individuals who
self-harm and actually it's a little in
the rest of the world people don't
separate out self non-suicidal
self-injury from suicide attempts
typically they lumped self all kinds of
self harm together so people who
self-harm are twenty four point seven
times more likely to die by suicide so
that's a pretty high high rate but the
thing that I think that's really
important for us to think about because
as clinicians when we when we're talking
with people there is a kind of a
tendency to kind of like formulate in
your head okay is this person at risk or
not at risk and so
[Music]
we pretty much know now that if somebody
made a prior suicide attempt we should
be worried about them making another
suicide attempt however over fifty
percent of people who die by suicide
have made no prior attempt in other
words on their first attempt they die
and so it's if we can't rest easy in
other words if if we say oh well that
person doesn't have a prior attempt
they're not going to be at risk for
suicide okay so up to the 1980s suicidal
behavior was seen as a symptom of
depression a borderline personality
disorder even though we then talked
about borderline that much of
schizophrenia or substance abuse in
other words suicidal behavior was looked
at only in the context of a formal
diagnosis and and so the thinking was
then the way to treat suicidal behaviors
you treat the primary disorder and the
suicidal behavior goes away but actually
there was a change in perspective about
this where we began to look at this in a
little different way where we saw this
is and this is kind of what the current
thinking is that psychiatric disorder is
a is is a necessary but it's not a
sufficient condition and so we are
trying to grapple with what is the other
things that goes on here that make
psychiatric disorders not the only but
what else do we have to look for on and
so the reason that we we know this is
not everybody who is depressed dies by
suicide or makes a suicide attempt or in
fact is that is suicidal at all and so
the so the way that we have started
thinking about this is we're kind of
going in a direction and and and Joe's
talk is kind of giving me pause about
this and
I talked about this with a little bit of
trepidation here with him in the
audience but we're starting to think
about suicidal subtypes that one size
doesn't fit all and the place that we're
starting from is this so I was lucky in
a treatment study that we're just kind
of wrapping up now we did we decided to
do ecological momentary assessment which
is you give somebody a little thing to
carry around now when we use an iPod and
they get paying several times a day and
they fill out a bunch of ratings and so
we gave these to our patients all of
whom have borderline personality
disorder we gave them to carry over the
course of a week six times a day they
were pinged and we looked at the
character of their suicide ideation over
the course of a week so what is
interesting about it is these patients
all had borderline personality disorder
so I would have thought that this would
be like what my borderline patients
would be like but in fact that was not
true this is a subgroup of people with
borderline personality disorder and this
is another subgroup so you have people
who have ideation that is all over the
place over the course of a week that's
really tough if you're thinking about
clinically they're up and then they're
down and then they're up and then their
town and then what do you do with those
patients these were the people who I who
go to the emergency room and and they
convinced they try to convince the staff
there that they're no longer suicidal
and often they get shipped off to a
hospital but in fact they are no longer
suicidal because they're like this on
and then there is this other kind of
subgroup and so what we started thinking
about is okay so how can we understand
so say this is really an important
meaningful difference in people and we
really can identify these these highly
variable from these not so variable and
so this is where I were supposed to be
getting funded any minute now
to look at these two suicidal subtypes
and so it's really I we we kind of have
a sense of what this subtype is so this
is kind of more the reactive one the one
that goes up and down so the stress
responsive subtype and in fact we have
data now but I'm not going to show here
that these people
we've gave the tree err social stress
test to these patients which is you it's
it's kind of um you put people in in a
room where they give they give a little
bit of a speech and they they do what
backwards arithmetic test and then you
get their cortisol levels over time and
so um and so you can look at their
cortisol response over time and in fact
what we found is these the highly
variable type this one had a much higher
cortisol response to to to the stress
then these guys so so we're looking at
this kind of stress response of stress
reactive subtype and then we have played
with what exactly is this one called and
so well it I really think about it as
kind of like the depressogenic subtype
the more chronic or the non stress
responsive and this was what we think
about as having a more low serotonergic
activity so that's kind of weird that's
just a little bit of kind of give you a
taste of like where our research is
going and what we're thinking about it
ok so now I'm just gonna kind of switch
back to talking about suicidal behavior
in the context of borderline personality
disorder and then talk about strategies
that we have for managing people with
suicidality and you know one of the
things that's really interesting the
name of this conference is suicidality
but from the CDC it's a no-no to say
suicidality right and which I actually
happen to really like that term because
it really in
compasses all of being suicidal
okay so nearly ten percent of people
with borderline personality disorder die
by suicide so the the figures vary and
this is probably the upper limit of it
but it's a lot and if you kind of go
backwards and look at the universe of
people who die by suicide anywhere from
nine to thirty three percent of
individuals have borderline personality
disorder so these figures actually are
not that great because a lot of studies
do not include looking at access - it
just doesn't and and you still I still
have colleagues at Columbia who think
that borderline personality disorder
does not really exist that if you treat
the depression the borderline
personality disorder will go away and
and this is actually this is still or
it's a variant on on bipolar disorder or
it's some sort of atypical depression
something like that um so um but the
it's pretty striking that if you when
you do look at studies that do look at
access to diagnosis um there's a high
rate of people who die by suicide um for
in borderline personality disorder up to
70% of individuals with with BPD have
cut burned hit or otherwise injured
themselves self hitting is a very big
problem we often don't ask about it
but people take objects and hit
themselves in the head or they hid
themselves in the hair or they bang
their heads against the wall and then
non-suicidal self-injury does in fact
predict future suicidal behavior so um
what's the problem of working with
suicidal behavior in the context of
borderline personality disorder that's a
little bit different say that in
depression so suicide attempts occur at
a much higher rate than suicide about
ten times as many attempts for every
suicide it's probably even a higher rate
in BPD than in any
their diagnosis the usual method of
attempt um in BPD is overdosing so what
happens is the high rate of attempts in
the chronicity of suicide ideation in
the borderline population makes for a
very complex picture and difficulties
assessing and managing risk so even for
example when two hospitalized are not
hospitalized when to send to the
emergency room or not to and this is
what you know we think about as the boy
who cried wolf phenomenon and it's
actually not faking it but I think that
the clinician who is treating the person
with borderline personality disorder who
was suicidal kind of takes that frame of
mind that well they they say they're
suicidal they say they're suicidal they
say they're suicidal and there's no
attempt on or they make a low lethality
attempt they make a low lethality
attempt that's all they're gonna do and
then they die by suicide and so but so
it's this kind of figure ground thing
that is very difficult in the context of
Bourdon personality disorder of you know
you have you have kind of like a high
base of suicidality suicide ideation
suicide attempts and low lethality
attempts and then how do you know when
it's going to be either a suicide death
or a very serious attempt and so that
the picture tends to lead to an
underestimation I think of suicide risk
in may and may in fact contributed to
the high risk of completion and so this
is kind of a a a poor explanation of
this they're trying to figure out
whether it's a chemical thing or I'm
just a crybaby
and I think that's what happens to a lot
of people with borderline personality
disorder they it's not real it's
whatever it is it's not real and and and
so the we tend to kind of like
underestimate or undervalue the the role
of this is in fact real ok non-suicidal
self-injury and BPD
occurs at a high rate um there is a big
overlap between people who self-injure
and the group would make suicide
attempts and so there is some thinking
about this that you know maybe there is
a kind of like a gait theory that once
you start one kind of self injurious
behavior that it allows you to move to
another level of self injurious behavior
um also common as I mentioned before our
self hitting head banging and skin
picking so one thing that I think is
interesting in suicidal behavior and
boiling personality disorder that can be
a little bit different than suicidal
behavior in say in major depression
often individuals with with BPD describe
their suicide attempts in the same kind
of way as self-injury episodes and it is
a kind of a thing that then people tend
not to believe that they were seriously
suicidal and and so suicide attempts in
this kind of strange way in the same way
that self-injury selves serves as a
emotion regulation function suicide
attempts can serve as a self-regulation
function and we really don't pay enough
attention to this and this really takes
me back all the way to my internship out
at at lij on Long Island where I came in
to my supervisor and I said like I don't
understand this was the time when they
it's a very long time ago they had still
had cottages there that were not locked
um and so somebody came in and he had
made a suicide attempt and with an
serious suicide attempt and within a
week he was the president of the patient
governance board and I said I went to my
supervisor and I said like I don't
understand this and she said ah that's
just shallow depression
and so it's like okay it's shallow
depression actually it was borderline
personality disorder on and so whatever
the attempt whatever the function of the
attempt was it served to kind of
stabilize the person and so I mean I
won't get into it but then there is a
question of what is the underlying
neurobiology what's happening in the
context of and I have some research
where I've looked at this in
non-suicidal self-injury what's
happening when somebody self injures
this is not like oh it's just a learning
function and we learn how to do
something we are biological animals
something is happening to us
biologically when we self injure that is
making us feel better
what is that um and so the same thing
kind of is happening often not all the
time in people with borderline
personality disorder okay so on the
thing I think that is really important
is that in our minds we often now
probably not in this audience but in a
general clinical audience I think we
walk around with a model of suicidal
behavior as kind of thinking about
suicidal behavior as a aspect of major
depression the depressed individual goes
into a protracted period of depressed
mood hopelessness withdrawal and
isolation and it can culminate in
feeling life is not worth living feeling
hopeless and then lead to a suicide
attempt
following the attempt if you've spoken
with people who have major depression
every now and then somebody is glad that
it wasn't successful often people talk
about feeling sorry that it wasn't
successful but the major depression
model doesn't seem to apply to suicide
attempts in BPD we try to apply it and
it leads us to the notion that the BPD
individual feels better afterwards
because the attempt was just
manipulative it was not really genuine
it was designed to get attention and we
just have to kind of move
that model and not thinking that model
at all this is an example I won't go
through this this is a typical example
you have it in your your handout of
somebody on who made a pretty serious
suicide attempt so if we compare on
suicidal behavior and BPD and borderline
personality disorder some of the
questions we can ask is does it have a
different phenomenology are the
after-effects of suicide attempt in BPD
different yes often people feel better
is the behavior less serious um what do
the precipitants differ and is there a
different biology okay so this was a
study that Beth Brodsky and I did a
while ago if you look at people who have
have a borderline personality disorder
they have they start their career of
suicidal behavior earlier they have more
suicide attempts at any given age but
it's really interesting if you look at
like what's the most serious suicide
attempt but they make it's the same as
major depression so it isn't just like
oh they just make a bunch of low
lethality attempts who cares you know
they're it's not good but it's not that
serious
it is serious there at lethality is
exactly the same they're just making
more low lethality attempts they have
greater hostility greater impulsivity
and greater history of aggressive
behaviors so that's a kind of a
difference between the two and you know
it's interesting because when we that
the model of those two type types that I
was talking about the two endo
phenotypes they actually when we start
to look at our data you would think oh
well maybe that's the borderline one and
that's the non borderline one but it
actually is not really true so you
shouldn't just think that that reactive
one is just borderline so if you think
about interpersonal events as triggers
for for suicide attempts in the
borderline as we heard earlier
today in the individual with borderline
personality disorder much more often an
interpersonal trigger on and so for
their first attempt their most recent
attempt in their most lethal attempt so
the interpersonal interpersonal
interactions are very complicated and
stressful for individuals with BPD okay
so so that kind of puts the context for
how are people with borderline
personality disorder different in terms
of their suicidal behavior than other
people on so now what how do we help
them what do we do as clinicians in in
treating individuals with BPD who are
suicidal so we have some suicide
specific psycho therapies there's DBT
there's MBT there's cognitive therapy
for suicide prevention but the reality
is that many clinicians are not in the
position to learn suicide specific
psycho therapies you know now that I
have this role within New York State of
developing and implementing suicide
prevention trainings throughout the
state I see what clinics are are tasked
with and what their workload is and the
number of patients and the variety of
patients that they see and so if I'm
going around as the suicide prevention
expert and say you know what you need to
learn this specific therapy for your
suicidal clients it's like you know it's
really it's nice but it's not realistic
however as somebody who has learned DBT
and CT you can kind of glean from that
what are some of the things that we can
do that can help suicidal people and in
fact in one of my treatment trials where
we were kind of doing we were comparing
DBT to clinical management I found that
certain kinds of a clinical management
makes led to very low incidence of
suicidal behavior and that started us
thinking of okay so what are those
techniques what are we doing here um and
so that's some of the things that I'm
gonna talk about here so um so and I'll
talk a little bit about each of these
things explicitly inquire about suicide
ideation now you would think that that
is a no-brainer
but it is not and somebody mentioned
earlier that people feel funny asking
about it sometimes and on and what
happens is people assume that if it's
not mentioned it's not present if in
working with suicidal people and this is
very hard often in clinical environments
but I'm just gonna say it you need a
flexibility in the clinical approach
I'll talk about that in a moment
you need to as like for me I was in
charge of my treatment study so I could
require documentation each and every
time there was evidence of any suicide
ideation of a collaborative plan for
managing suicidality now at the time we
hadn't developed the safety plan now we
have this this small intervention but
all I was asking the clinician to do was
each time your patient says to you I am
having suicide ideation I want the two
of you to develop a plan together about
how they're gonna manage it pretty
simple right but it doesn't get done um
consultation with colleagues is
extraordinarily important therapeutic
stance I'll talk a little bit about that
and then structuring techniques to
maintain the focus on suicidality so are
there do clinicians who have had a
suicidal who have had a patient who has
died by suicide learn anything from that
experience they there are tremendous
terrible emotional sequel I of that for
clinicians so um so these results
actually were shocking to me these were
this was not the intention of the
article the article
talked about about the how the clinician
basically felt the same after a suicide
of a patient as a family member did when
when their loved one died by suicide so
um so these are the results that were
surprising to me
so about 75% of them assess their
patient as suicidal about when you put
these two figures together about 50% of
them had asked their patient about
suicidality in their last appointment
and in retrospect only about a third of
them would have done anything different
so I'm thinking like wait a minute only
half of them asked a person who they had
known to be suicidal um that about their
suicidality and only about a third of
them would have done anything different
it's like oh wouldn't you think that you
would begin to start asking about
suicidality um so this is what we do um
we do ongoing if you know you have
somebody who has evidence of suicidality
we do ongoing monitoring of their
suicidality and that means cannot
assuming if they're not talking about
suicidal ideation that they're not
suicidal we conduct an affirmative
assessment of suicidal ideation on and
conduct affirm an affirmative assessment
of recent suicidal behavior so if you
have if you work with individuals with
borderline personality disorder you know
that they can have made a suicide
attempt a week ago two days ago come
into your office and have zero suicidal
ideation so if you just say are you
feeling suicidal now and they say no you
are missing you could be missing
something very big about not asking them
about their recent behavior
and in fact I remember as we were
developing the CSS RS I was insistent on
putting recent behavior on the screening
form of it because if you you can miss
picking up somebody who is in a
high-risk period if you do not ask about
recent behavior this is especially true
if you're working with borderline
patients and so um I put up this up
because this gives you a taste of me as
a clinician refusing to discuss this is
not an option on and so if you are my
patient you are going to talk about this
period you want to be my patient I am a
good clinician you have to be willing to
talk about this and there has to be this
kind of level of kind of communication
and trust that if I ask you this
question you will give me an honest
answer and so on so my patients know
that I am willing to tolerate a high
level of suicidality without
hospitalizing as long as I can trust
their honesty and these are like two
very important dimensions that we have
to take into account I and I and I have
this discussion very explicitly and any
you don't need to be doing DP thbbt NE b
t to be able to do this this is really
important to to establish when you're
working with the suicidal person and so
and this happens a lot if you work with
adolescents you know they they don't
want to talk about it you know and so um
so you have to establish a climate where
they they know that this is it's not an
option to not talk about it so the other
thing when I say affirmative assessment
I mean affirmative assessment you ask
about it on do not is assume that if
patients do not express suicide ideation
if they're not if they don't say so
on in patient after patient
with borderline personality disorder
this is what I have the most experience
with so really is speaking from the
place of working with individuals with
Boylan personality disorder so I will
say hey why don't you tell the clinician
about that well I didn't think the
clinician care or the clinician doesn't
want to hear about it
so he or she doesn't have to do anything
about the risk because it is a big pain
to have to deal with somebody who is
suicidal you have a this you know I've
had it in my private practice where you
know you're seeing patients one after
another and somebody says they're
suicidal and you feel like okay you know
I I have decided that this person
actually cannot leave now that they are
so extraordinarily suicidal I cannot
risk sending them home well that kind of
like you know that interrupts your
schedule and and so you have to be able
to kind of like own up to that
acknowledge that and not act on hey I
don't want my schedule interrupted um
and you know the interesting thing is
that if my schedule gets interrupted in
the context of this I never of course
talked about it with the patients who
are in the waiting room but they all
know why it got interrupted and they all
appreciate that I would do the same
thing for them so um so you want to try
to create a therapeutic environment that
encourages disclosure and so I'll talk
about that in a minute so flexibility
and approach this is really tough for
people who work in a clinic environment
on you if you have if you are working
with the suicidal population you have to
provide for increased contact during
periods of suicidal crisis so you
increase the number of appointments you
increase the intercession contact either
by phone or if you're comfortable with
email you can have patient check-in my
patients find this incredibly helpful um
they will call and leave me a message on
my machine saying you know it's Sally I
doing okay or I'm struggling but I'm
okay and they and I they don't need me
to call them back we we know in advance
we've made a plan in advance and and it
works out fine and they they know that
somebody else knows how they're doing
and then you need to consider options
for other forms of therapeutic support
hospitalization is always an option but
there are other options short of
hospitalization so of course there's
groups and there's day programs but one
of the things that I work on with my
patients is increasing your structure in
your day this seems pretty simple but
it's like you know you have somebody who
comes into your office and who is you
know basically getting out of their
apartment coming to their appointment
with you and then going back to there
it's like no that is not okay come up
with a schedule of activities that
you're going to because we know that
number one not having social contact is
a likelihood to increase depression and
and staying in your apartment or your
home alone leads you to stay within your
head and in your thoughts and so so you
you so you don't have to just think
about sending somebody to a day program
you can work with them on increasing
their structure so clinician
consultation and support are very very
important I work at at New York State
Psychiatric Institute and it happens
that in our division along our corridor
well everybody works on suicide we all
we do trials we do biological studies
and and so we're we've seen hundreds of
suicidal individuals we are constantly
knocking on each other's door asking
about what do you think about this
particular person I'm worried do you
think I should do this do you think I
should do that the person will often say
would you like me to talk with them do
you want another you know or or spend
time so it's really important if you
have a doubt in your mind have some
colleagues that you can consult with
knowing DBT we have a team you know but
if you're not doing DBT you can still
find a few colleagues that you can trust
that you can kind of swap support with
in consultation with and all I can say
is that experience helps the more you
work with suicidal people the better you
are at it period the more that you work
with suicidal people the less likely you
are to hospitalize them because you have
kind of a context and you have a feel
for it's like I collect Crocs with blue
designs these old you know from the
1700s 1800s in America they you put me
you know flour or oil in these Crocs
carried them home with the cork on top
of them
and so some of the Crocs have blue
designs if you have collected enough of
these Crocs looked at enough of these
Crocs you know which is a fake blue
design and which is a real blue design
how does that happen you know I
you don't naturally know oh this cobalt
blue it looks this way and this way
it's from experience so the more you
work with suicidal people the more you
know same as knowing which is a fake
croc and which isn't um okay so this I
want to talk about for a minute um is
the therapists stance so it's you have
to come and working with suicidal people
from a position of strength you have to
balance concern for the patient without
being overly anxious this is not so easy
and and the the reality is that I have
worked I have supervised some clinicians
who actually when you work with them and
work with them they actually shouldn't
be working with suicidal people because
they they just don't have it in them my
daughter-in-law is going to be is a
surgeon it's like well I could never in
my wildest dreams be a surgeon I can't
stand the sight of blood
and so on so part of it is knowing
yourself and there are some people who
just aren't made for working with
suicidal people that's okay I'm not
really made for working with people who
are just anxious it's like I just want
to say well hey stop that there's
nothing to be anxious about but give me
somebody who is cutting burning and
acutely suicidal and I know what to do
and I feel comfortable with that so part
of it is kind of so in a clinic
environment you may not have this option
um but I in a private practice
environment I think it's really
important to kind of know yourself
um so the type of inquiry when you're
asking about suicidality people know if
you are extremely anxious
it's matter-of-fact but serious and so
there is this kind of like tension
you're asking this question about their
suicide ideation and their suicidal
behavior in the same way that you ask
any other kind of question not more not
less therapists need to not worry too
much but yeah and and they and you have
to develop a certain level of tolerance
for
suicidality and so this really comes
into play if you have established a
relationship with a patient where they
are honest and so I can have I can
tolerate your suicidality if I know
you're being dead-on honest with me and
so you need this kind of tolerance for a
certain level of suicide suicidality so
you hear it you acknowledge it you
listen to it it isn't like you don't pay
attention to it you say I see you're
feeling suicidal and you and and so
that's balancing it with a sense of
caring about the suicide alledge so you
care about it but you're not gonna go
crazy about it and you're not going to
and hospitalized the person this
immediately this is really important
because the more that you are anxious
and moved to hospitalized the and you
keep that person in your practice the
less likely they are to tell you about
their suicidality in the future I have
patients who go to a particular day
program and they say well I never tell
the group about X Y or Z because I'll
get kicked out they have been taught
they've seen somebody get kicked out and
they don't want to get kicked out and so
they they don't disclose but get then
they're walking around with this and so
as a therapist we have to kind of walk
this tightrope and then you take a
collaborative problem-solving approach
okay
so discuss in advance how the two of you
will handle suicidal crises develop a
safety plan I think that no suicidal
patients should ever leave a first
appointment without some rudimentary
safety plan so you know when you work in
a clinic environment you have a first
appointment how how much how thick is
the stack of forms well now it's on the
computer that you have to fill out you
know so how important is it to get
somebody's history of psychiatric
hospitalization in that first
appointment versus giving them a tool
that they can leave with and possibly
keep themselves alive till their next
appointment and so this is a tough sell
to clinics and hospitals but it's but
it's kind of a to me in my mind it's a
no-brainer so when we talk about a
safety plan we really want to
differentiate it from no suicide
contracts we kind of don't do so with no
suicide contracts anymore a no suicide
contract asks a person to promise to
stay alive without telling them how to
do it we think we can do better in New
York State we have adopted what we call
this a model which is assess intervene
and monitor and the and this is what we
talk about when we go to clinics like
this is like your Bay
sick of suicide care you assess you do
some sort of basic intervention and you
do some sort of follow-up monitoring
okay so I just want to talk for a little
bit I know I don't have a lot of time
left here about the safety plan
intervention that my colleague Greg
Brown and I developed on Seth mentioned
it earlier we have data now supporting
that we get a reduction in over a
six-month period of time by about 45
percent in suicidal behaviors for people
who have this they have a higher rate of
engaging in further treatment so it's a
it's a it's a clinical and intervention
that develop that results in a one-page
document to use when a suicidal crisis
is emerging we are now doing it with a
group from Braun and Michigan State in
for suicidal people in jails and they
are trying to implement this Edie
Boudreaux and at the University of
Massachusetts is trying to implement
this in emergency rooms and actually the
most difficult place to to get this
administered is in the context of
emergency departments who say they don't
have time to to do this intervention
okay so so what are the strategies that
that are in on the safety plan what we
did was we put the safety plan together
we went to the literature and we just
looked okay what's the evidence base
what has some support in the literature
for reducing suicide and so we means
restriction was one of them brief
problem-solving and coping including
distraction I happen to be a huge fan of
distraction in the context of a crisis
enhancing social support is related to a
protective factor of course identifying
an emergency contacts and then a little
bit of motivational enhancement for for
further treatment so
why a safety plan so one of the things
that we know is that even for my group
that had relatively stable suicide
ideation and people that went up and
down the actual period of risk for
acting on a suicidal urge and it's so
interesting in the field we don't we
talk about behaviors and we talk about
ideation we do not talk about urges we
talk about you know urges to self injure
why do we not talk about urges for a
suicide attempt um because that's
actually what people have they do have
urges and so the the period of time
where the urge is very strong is
actually very limited and so when you
talk with people who have who go through
these crises they talk about kind of
like white-knuckling it through that
period of time like just kind of holding
on till the urges pass and so what we
decided to do was give them something to
do while the urge is happening and so
the the theoretical foundation and this
isn't like a small t suicide risk
fluctuates with time time is your friend
if you are suicidal and we really forget
that and that's why restricting access
to means to firearms is so incredibly
important it's really important because
um if we get rid of that or put a
distance between why why does that work
if somebody wants to go out and kill
themselves they can but but then the
reason is because suicidal urges pass on
problem-solving capacity diminishes with
during crises so over practice or a
specific template can help that's like
um during Fire Prevention Week my kids
we used to come we lived up on a hill
they would come baby rolling down the
hill it's like oh it's Fire Prevention
Week because they learn to stop drop and
roll and so why why is it so we we know
that kind of like over practicing having
a specific thing in when you're in
emergency situation is helpful and so
that's what the safety plan is about
and one of the things that I would have
you remember is how many of you have had
a patient come into your office once and
never saw them again so if that person
is suicidal wouldn't you like to give
them something that they might be able
to use when they when they leave so um
so we just have I'm going to just go
through these what are the steps we do
we have them recognize the warning signs
they can't know to use a safety plan if
they don't know when to use it
we have them and we this is a stepwise
thing and this comes from really kind of
like trying to help shape behavior and
from helping them learn the more that
they do this the more they they have the
capability to manage their suicidal
feelings and so the idea is that they do
this do this do this that it will kind
of become automatic kind of like riding
a bike
so we we Furr we have them identify
things they could do by themselves
people that they can use as distractions
who to contact that they um who can help
them in a crisis so you can see that in
New York I don't know if it's true up
here but in New York everybody puts on
their their answering machines at work a
if you are in an emergency go to the
nearest emergency room or call 9-1-1
actually I think we can do better than
that you know what if you have if you
have an anxious patient in your practice
would you say um you know if you get we
all think of it if you get suicidal call
me or go to the emergency room if you if
would you say to the anxious patient if
you get anxious call me know you teach
them skills so that's the idea be we can
teach people skills suicidal feelings
are just like any other feelings they're
scarier they result in a horrible
outcome but they're just like any other
feelings that can also be managed so
then we have them identify who their
contacts are so in other words we as
clinicians are not first on the list if
it's a real emergency and they feel like
they can
handle anything yes of course we tell
them to to contact them or go there near
the nearest emergency room so then we
also have them identify what are their
access to means what would they use
would have they used and we always talk
about firearms this is an example of a
safety plan you can go to our website
and download these forms it's suicide
safety plan calm okay and then lastly
the only other thing that I'm going to
mention here is using structure as a
strategy for managing suicidality and
the the reason is that when you work
with people with continual crises and
continual stressors you need to stay on
the path where they to help them with
their suicidality or you can get
derailed this often happens with
borderline patients by moment-to-moment
crises okay so these are structuring
techniques they are in in there and CBT
or DBT setting an agenda conducting
behavioral analyses and balancing
validation with problem solving okay so
I you have the other things in the the
description of these things in your
pamphlet I won't go through them in the
interest of time here so just in
conclusion I will say look we have a
problem in the United States with
suicide it's growing we haven't tackled
it yet suicidality in the context of
borderline personality disorder has to
be taken seriously we cannot neglect it
just because it occurs very often
and while suicide specific psycho
therapies have been developed most
clinicians will not be able to learn
them but we can all learn simple
clinical strategies that can be used
even in the absence of suicide specific
psychotherapy training and then I found
this quote by Karl Menninger hope is a
necessity for normal life and the major
weapon against the suicidal impulse and
my patients would describe me as an
eternal optimist or somebody once
described me as stubbornly hopeful and I
think if you are a clinician working
with suicidal individuals you have to
maintain that position of stubborn
hopefulness and then I just want to
thank my research team and all of my
patients who have contributed to our
research thank you
Thank You dr. Stanley for an excellent
talk on we have several questions here
I'm going to go through a couple and
then we'll hold the rest for the panel
is there any research on the
effectiveness of the safety planning
yeah so um you know I did I purposely
didn't do a data talk today but we have
we have a lot of data on the
acceptability and feasibility of it we
have data now that it's like we have a
parallel group design where we gave
safety plans in the emergency department
in the VA and then we had a comparison
group where they didn't get them and
that was the data that I referenced
earlier where we have a 45 percent
reduction in lower number of suicidal
behaviors in the safety plan group in
addition they're much more likely to
engage in follow-up care we are now we
think we're going to be funded to do a
straight-up randomized control trial
which we've been trying to do but
because safety planning has become so
broadly accepted it's been hard to get
that trial funded but we think that it's
really important to really just look at
its efficacy alone in an RCT thank you
how would you suggest that clinical
staff shall determine lethality in the
kind of boy who cried wolf cases that
you're mentioning and and how can they
kind of protect themselves legally when
how can they protect themselves or
colleagues legally if they determine
that the patient is not really a
high-risk oh gosh I mean legally you I
mean you always take a risk and I don't
know that it's and I'll put aside the
the malpractice kind of thing which I
gather is what you're talking about
um you know it's as I said the more that
you work with suicidal people the more
you kind of get a feel for it the more
you have established a an open and
and trusting relationship and that comes
in a bed of having patients feel
comfortable talking about their
suicidality with you and knowing that
you won't just neglect it but also
knowing that you won't overreact to it
and so it's you know it's one of these
things it's really a kind of a fine
clinical distinction that you you have
to make and and the other thing is what
I would say is that if somebody is
suicidal and they're suicidality is
increasing I increase my monitoring in
my contact so it isn't like I say oh I
get that you're you're feeling suicidal
but you're not that suicidal that you
need to be hospitalized
it isn't like an all-or-none thing it's
like okay you're feeling suicidal you're
suicidality has escalated what can we do
to help you manage the suicidality now
then we'll do another check in and see
if it's lower and then again and again
and so I I think that that's pretty
protective I have I have a safety plan I
have a plan for monitoring and I've
never been sued and I've never had
anybody who's died by suicide well thank
you very much dr. Stanley we'll revisit
the rest of the questions at the panel
but thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you